and now some of you watching this may
not already know Andrew W okay and
that's a shame you really should known
as a rockstar for partying hard he's
actually a really intelligent guy with a
lot of insight from his Fox News
appearances to his Village Voice help
column I guess you'd call it you have to
read it too just getting a show now with
Glenn Beck's blazed radio network the
guy does a lot of cool stuff and he's
got some interesting things to say so we
caught up with him on a solo tour at a
Western Michigan staple derby station
pub to just hear his thoughts about life
so we're here with Andrew W K thank you
sir for taking the time thank you for
having me happy fritter where I'm not
having you this is actually it's a cool
little pub here in Grand Rapids Derby
station yes in this Irish themed expose
or it's sort of just I don't know I know
you really like Irish pubs oh that place
Gabby's I was reading yes yes yes well
thank you for being familiar with that I
was found not just in terms of
atmosphere but especially in terms of
service that there was a standard level
of quality that was maintained very
consistently at Irish pubs bars you know
themed restaurants all across at least
the u.s. yeah and as someone who you
know maybe wasn't always the most
approachable or didn't look like the
kind of person that should be served in
an establishment a respectable place I
was always impressed that they always
treated everyone no matter if they were
a regular or like some guy who looked
like me walking in you know never having
been there was always treated well but
that bartenders at those places so I
think this because in Ireland your high
society oh really
I know bar fights are a way of life oh
yeah yeah well I'm a pacifist because
the bar Fighting's oh you look like
you've been working out there so try to
exercise you know get have some fun and
partying actually counts as exercise so
that helps as well the shows are very
good good exercise tonight I can they'll
burn about a thousand calories well your
shows do well yes is not quite the same
as yo-yo ma going up there and well hey
you know a cello that's no joke that's
what that doesn't I'd see it takes a lot
of stamina maybe not the same as you
know prancing right banging I do do a
lot of prancing but
yeah it is it's a choice to perform in
an athletic style right now do you feel
like you have to you have to gear up
like Alice Cooper I don't know if you
ever read his biography is fascinating
he talks about his routine where he goes
in he gets into character
he eats one chocolate chip cookie cuz
that's the right amount of sugar and
then he watches kung fu movies for like
45 minutes I may not have the numbers
exactly right and then the room has to
be dark for half an hour I don't have to
sleep but I just have to rest for half
and I had no idea
I never that's very elaborate for yeah
in any profession to prepare to that
degree the cookie I can relate to is I
do like cookie but no I've never I think
stretching out I think stretching out
that's my routine you know just so you
don't pull a hamstring or right you know
dislocate your knee which I've done
before I've broken my foot I've broken
my nose
definitely lot of pulled muscles but
stretching seems to be a good sort of
also meditative yeah focus state I do
that too before stand-up and it's my I
actually thought my knee it was I'm
doing by twisting your leg and keeping
your body listener won't want to hear
this but I want to hear your story mine
was with this so there was you know
sometimes they build those state is
unlike those multi-purpose sort of
wooden blocks yes yeah so they're
gradual er yeah and they're supposed to
like contain them somehow but the kid
didn't it was at a college so they
shifted apart so I'm walking my heels
flips in and stays but the ball of my so
it's like a brace yeah I keep walking
but my shin stays perpendicular as I
fall over and it's it's still not like
I'm looking at surgery I mean people
don't realize and it's not I'm gonna
have a pretty energetic show what you do
is is crazy mean how long is the show
it's over an hour right well this these
shows tonight it will be an hour long
okay the longest you've done this yeah
how are 45 minutes to two hours our show
because of that kind of energy level
that the style of music it doesn't lend
itself well to join much longer than
four and a half yes the crowd also
they're going full-blown mmm so to be
sprinting for an hour and a half is
that's that's asking a lot of anybody
right and I think there's a more
effective kind of contra
when you just blow it all out and then
it's done right and then that you just
sort of been this days of what just
happened do you feel like exercising it
helps translate to that like I have one
my advice one time where someone says
hey kid
as an actor stand-up I said your career
is not a sprint it's a marathon and I
thought it's it's really not it's more
like interval training you know cousin
Marg high impact interval training
that's a much better comparison okay cuz
it is it's dynamic yeah and there's
moments even in any career where the
only way you can really appreciate
anything you've done is people have a
time to reflect on it to absorb it I
think that's the most important thing
when being very busy it's not so much
that even want to reflect and think oh
that was really fun when I did this two
weeks ago or last year it's great to
remember back you're going through so
much so fast in life in general actually
with anyone with that or whatever their
pursuits are but I feel like you have to
actually give your soul time to absorb
yeah your own life to put it into
perspective within yourself and it might
not even be a very formalized literal
way of thinking about it it just you
just kind of have to like be like a
sponge and soap it all up and you know
it's funny I mean you're very
introspective guy and yeah I mean I've
read quite a bit of your um you're sort
of I guess I don't even call advice
columns yeah okay advice columns and do
you feel like there's this image I mean
obviously people take party and you sort
of put it out there's more of a
generality as like a positive experience
but you think people maybe have an image
of you that's not inherently accurate
like they picture you know like you're
very calm well-spoken introspective guy
you think people expect like the party I
can do that do I know and you're good
with that I can go well we're here in
know having some fun of it we're gonna
smash things and then run amok us and
that's just when there's times when
that's called hour you're in a moment
actually you have a very high energy
level the the way I've seen you carrier
your program
it's definitely amped up right but I
usually just respond to whatever the
atmosphere is calling for and try to I
don't know mirror the
surroundings in a way that adds to it
you know right I'm not here with some
kind of a mole that I have to get across
the certain thing like schtick yeah
because it just doesn't feel right I
don't know uh I'm more interested in
trying to communicate yeah that's what
we're trying to we were sort of talking
about this do you feel like because a
lot of entertainment now people are age
relatively are age a lot of
entertainment and will go to a breaks
you know but is very conversational like
podcast that's that's true it's sort of
a rigid I almost feel like it's because
our parents they had their conversations
in the house and then they turn on TV
and gee willikers you know but now we're
so engaged in our devices that we want
our entertainment to feel more real oh
that's interesting
maybe you're compensating for not having
as many conversations throughout the day
because of Technology the computer or
even just sort of your lifestyle and
then you want to listen to other people
yeah
to make up for that that Lloyd I mean
this would never play on traditional
media you know there's ago this is
engrossing there's something about it
that's very unique at the podcast
phenomena it's a style and it's a tone
unto itself yeah I couldn't mean it but
I just noticed that I'd find myself
becoming more consumed with old we'll
talk we'll talk more after the break um
so we first met I think was it a fox
news greenroom
oh yeah I think it might've been red ah
yeah yeah I know I had done things by
satellite so let me ask you this I you
don't necessarily go out and discuss
politics oh you've had some interesting
political insights that I've taken with
me that you may not even realize how
influential they work but do you feel
like in the industry where you are have
you had any blowback just for going on
Fox News because I was like this dirty
word have you felt that at all from
people much less than I ever would have
imagined okay when I first went on TV in
general like MTV I got to Dussehra alive
right the beginning my first album cycle
of my beginning of my career we did
Conan and I got general blowback from a
lot of my friends who thought just doing
anything on TV at all was bad that it
would go evil corporate like what you
were saying earlier here ad sponsors but
it was playing into this machine
not that that
I should avoid but I completely
disagreed and Ashley was expecting that
because a lot of these friends of mine
that I've grown up with
we're very against the grain I mean
really radical in almost off the grid
type live this isn't an arbor yes is in
Upper Michigan but that was always very
much interested and stimulated by that
kind of far-out thinkers sure but didn't
really relate to it personally because I
like TV
I like Saturday Night Live and it was
like the greatest thrill my whole life
to be able to go on there's a great
performance to not to kiss-ass one thank
you for being familiar with it so then
over the years I just always liked
television I always liked being able to
have this thing that my that my thing
could be able to go on those places go
into these other realms where maybe I
don't fit in or maybe you wouldn't
expect me to go and actually have it be
okay and makes sense and so by the time
things like Fox News came around I was
still wondering or what and there were a
few people that said oh they're evil you
know go on there it was much less than I
expected and I actually more than take
credit for that personally I think that
just shows that well maybe I have a
really great audience that affords that
kind of open-mindedness so whatever I'm
doing or maybe they just realize it's
not really what I mean I'm not I don't
have an agenda right beyond really sort
of good cheer so no no they cut me a lot
of slack I guess I will say that I
noticed there are two places on the
internet that aren't horrible your
Twitter feed and Art of Manliness is
actually a website we had to found
earlier they're very very positive oh it
seems like I mean I'm sure everyone gets
people who hate them it seems like you
don't get a lot of people who live to
hate like I've never run it okay there's
a few out there but uh you know I try to
take their comments and strive like even
even today I was thinking about this
there's and you I'm sure deal with this
a lot and I am most people hate me well
I expect you to leave you like Jesus guy
was a jackass
and a default mode that you can operate
in yeah you know it makes it easier to
to realize what you're up against at all
times but it seems like there's sort of
with whenever you put yourself out there
when you decide to do something that is
a public offering
yeah entertainment radio right anything
that worked what you're asking someone
to consider it to give their time to it
you're gonna get this kind of feedback
so the question is like it's the
comments section of life do you
completely avoid at the comment section
of life and not look at all look what
I'm saying do you look at it and then
really get upset by it right or is there
a way to actually look at it and try to
extract something from it and that's
what I it's very challenging it's
beautiful that's what I've been trying
to do like maybe they're right it's like
some of these criticisms like I went on
the show the other day I'm glad back
again and some of the criticisms that
people had about my comments I agreed
with them yeah and it didn't feel great
to realize that I slightly misspoke or
could have said something better and
couldn't go back and change it right but
it felt very good that I could take
really what was sort of mean-spirited
criticism and say like you know what
they have a point there and that takes
away this whole this stuff tell you that
though in my youtube just littered with
people calling me a Jew [ __ ] so maybe
well what you could glean from it would
be that you are not blocking out right
the world just because it's threatening
and I think it goes back to count over
time about rhythms and margins like
there are times where I can go on
YouTube I mean cuz that's my world right
and be with all of the Fox News and
people didn't really like it was extreme
liability there's no worse place in the
YouTube section for some twitter and
there are times where I can look at it
and get inspired and say okay can you
know Bruce Lee absorb the good right
discard the bat and then there are times
where I just know mentally I'm not in
the place where I can handle it all go
you just have to avoid it well that's
like you know if you're home alone and
you're feeling on edge and it's a dark
stormy night maybe it's not the best
choice to watch a horror movie that
night or for some people it is new it's
the best meaning pick and choose your
moments when you have that kind of
internal strength to face things that
are designed to be challenging these
people are trying to challenge
you I mean a lot of times they're just
you know trolling as they say trying to
rile you up trying to get under your
skin but even that I want to be strong
enough to let people get under my skin
yeah and see what that's like so it's
it's it's a pretty far-out place I don't
know if I'll ever be combat I don't know
what the way enlightens where I can
actually go through life with with that
kind of impenetrable vulnerability yeah
it's a strange gonna be hard for you you
know what and I'm not I'm not saying
this to sound like authoritative but
you're as an artist as someone who's
obviously very creative something as a
comedian you know you can't be
thick-skinned in the sense that what
makes you able to create something makes
you inherently thin-skinned it makes you
sensitive to pick up on things and
create something out of that that's a
good good observation I think yeah like
you want to be weak enough to be you
want to be strong enough to be weak
enough Brennan mean like that a really
strong person isn't strong just in this
way to barricade themselves from real
world they're strong enough to actually
be vulnerable yeah it's this very
strange paradox we talked about that too
with another guest you know there's this
sort of I talked about this sort of this
I guess vilifying of masculinity
nowadays and I'm not talking about some
false sense of machismo and hunting and
fishing but I think boys are very
confused and I think a big part of that
too is also you have people saying that
you know men are inherently you know
you're male privilege is showing and
they make them feel guilty but then you
have people acting like well you're
either the jock or you're the book nerd
when if you look at people even like
Patton you look at people like Churchill
you look at great men they all were very
very very layered people you know back
then if you were only considered a
complete man if you were intelligent if
you were creative if you were
well-spoken and if you had the physical
whereas how he told me like it's it's
one or the other right you're a type of
person right that's a really great
observation I like that idea
you're trying to assemble many types of
people into one layered as you said and
and and synchronised whole we're all
those things actually it's not like that
you you're this way one minute you're
this way they're all working in tandem
to sort of bring out the best that you
can
a complete yeah well that's a that's a
great that's something to aspire to how
well thank you see you're making me
yards a great human yeah well I guess I
was talking worse about men because
we've had feminists in the show who just
you know you're patriarchy showing like
dammit they just had the fittest had
that I don't even know if I can said
they had the [ __ ] walk just yesterday
but what's that you walk around naked
and call men rapists they do it they do
it across many cities okay so anyway
that's that's why my mind was there but
and then jeremy renner got a bunch of
flack I'm sure you heard for the black
widow comment no it was really funny he
said the black widow in the comics
doesn't sleep with Captain America and
then quite sleep with side yeah yeah and
let me say he said yeah I said Black
Widow a fictional characters like she's
just a total [ __ ] and now feminists are
furious okay so you've been unlocked as
you appear in the Glenn Beck stuff right
and I'm sure you get people who think
you know it would you fear on Hitler's
show now you've never really been open
about your politics as far as like
saying I'm a conservative or putting a
label on it but I would have to imagine
just in being accepting of the
invitations to those programs that
you're not like a far left II anything
right I was thinking about this earlier
today maybe an in anticipation of coming
on the show I don't think there was a
time when I ever identified as anything
great a lot largely because I was
extremely uneducated still M just sort
of ignorant not proud of it either on a
lot of the issues I didn't feel prepared
or even capable of picking a position
all the time and so I just wasn't
interested in it I just really wasn't
interested if Ida labeled myself I would
want to have been you know label as a
musician or as a painter or as you know
a person so I just didn't find that kind
of engaging with the world through a
political point of do you feel like it
has to become more aware though because
you had people going like why
why would you go on glycerin so uh did
that make you know like well why am I
going on glenn back cuz this really bad
dirt no I hate because he asked me
exactly that's how I've gone through
life is more and more a sense of there's
something pulling me along and I can
fight it or I can show up and do it
and the more I've shown up and done it
sometimes against my instincts sometimes
against the advice of people I really
trust and respect but gave into a deeper
more subtle pull that I was supposed to
be pulled towards these things I've just
followed it and things have been worked
out I really would like to be able to
take these case-by-case as much as
possible in life right and while that
might not always be possible we we do
need to sort of have preset ways of
looking at the world in order just to
move through it right I try to stay
focused on open-mindedness as the
default mode right even question that in
a question everything even including
questioning everything so it can get
exhausting not resting on a certain
point of view but it's been for me it's
been more I've learned a lot more than I
think I would have if I had just stayed
with one point of view and then right to
to defend it well you've got to
recognize that that's different from a
lot of because I call every you know
rock star gardening and they ask us what
every rocks are like considers
themselves open-minded but not most them
would never even think of doing a show
that has someone labelled as a
conservative attached to it so do you
think it's maybe they're fooling
themselves into thinking they're
open-minded and you're just really
because it seems like you're very
sincere that's the one thing I think
like no one really hates you is because
it's contagious your authenticity you're
very nice I don't know what to say to
that
I just I'm trying to have an adventure
right in life and I feel as an
entertainer because that still is my dad
that's you if I'm not entertained by my
own life how can I enter not how would I
be able to entertain other people that's
a good oh I I don't know why other
people don't do what I do or why I don't
do what other people do I just I'm doing
what I'm supposed to do not even what I
want to do sometimes
right what I meant
and it's been hard to figure that out
but I'm getting better at following it
gosh that means it open to so many
questions when you say what do you say
meant to do like what do you feel is
drawing you what is it do you know the
universe God all all of that of enough
force maybe your own internal instincts
again but it but I've noticed what I
feel like I'm being useful that I'm
adding something rather than just taking
away or taking to make my life better
when I feel like someone else can relate
to something that I've offered and it's
made them feel good or it's allowed them
to tap into the part of themselves that
already did feel good they didn't
realize it anything that sort of to make
me feel like I was making I was
contributing that was because there was
things I wanted to do because I liked it
or I wanted to make money because of
this so I could buy this or live in a
certain way they're always left there
was always a slight flatness after you
didn't like the striving for the
achievement was satisfying but the kind
of end result when when there wasn't
another person involved it wasn't as
rewarding so I started thinking that
maybe could try to not just cheer myself
up but are there other people up that's
a great but well we'll keep going for
one more segment if you can yeah well
because that leaves me with something to
bring up bladder with Crowder after the
break
so we're back with a new wk and you were
talking about that talk about creating
and how if you're not entertaining
yourself you know it's funny because and
I've never talked about this but when I
first met you I don't and when I started
at Fox News I was 21 well it's not about
Fox News but New York you love New York
I hated it I mean I was I did it when I
first got there did you yeah I did at
two different stints and it just it just
it just wasn't me and you could sense
that like if you go back and you watch
the hits I was doing on television if
you go back you can just sense that
there's I mean if people listen to the
show or people watch the videos they're
like I think Stevens a bit of you know I
think he's a bit of a gherkin as a point
of view but he seems like a happy guy
you could sense that I wasn't happy I
know with comedy it's it's because
there's no there really is no unless
you're like
gosh I'm trying to think like a
character like a pee-wee Herman or
something you know you're doing a
character it's just you and that really
is reflected in comedy it comes out you
feel like that's the same thing with
your music where if you're in a state
where not only you're not entertaining
yourself but you don't feel like you're
really perfect pursuing or fulfilling
what you're meant to do then it it can
ya go you're destroying your soul yeah
and that's paint that could be cathartic
for other people to see someone going
through that in a dramatic way but
ultimately you know it's true you want
to see people that are feeling inspired
I do my best work when I'm gonna kick
excited about life when I feel like I'm
maybe not figuring things out but at
least going towards some kind of purpose
or meaning I mean there's times when
I've thought that everything was
meaningless I went through all kinds of
complete ambivalence and sort of tore
away everything about life and then
built it back up again and now I'm in a
building back up again phase which I
hope never stops I don't want to tear it
down again all right let's do didn't you
know you can die when you do things like
that but if you feel like you have to
then sometimes you're right
crap I got to do this again we go
through our deals in life and you hope
that you come out of them yes longer and
at the time it can seem like why how
could this ever be valuable but those
dark moments I feel like especially and
I'm not sure what your childhood was
like I had a very very privileged
upbringing you know just a good family
yeah I'm the support great surroundings
with friends and and and mentors
everywhere and things were so good I
think that I almost had to create bad
experiences so I could have a full
version of life I mean your parents of
course they want you just have this
perfect right existence but you don't
get to know yourself or even the world
unless I've you know for better or worse
you go through some bad stuff and even
if you have to make it happen on your
own right you can at the end of the day
you have to look yourself in the mirror
and say I mean have I done everything
that I could do did I do everything that
was in my power to make sure that I'm
prepared for whatever it is it you know
whether it's a show or whether it's you
know the next stage of life and that's a
scary moment I feel like because if you
can say yes you go to work and you're
willing to accept the result for me I
don't know about you like as far as a
tearing down phase
it's it's this is kind of the question
for me and it has nothing to do with
politics no people on the am dial might
be shutting this off but you never know
that's not like it depends on who's
listening what are the harder failures
to handle for you
the ones where you've made a mistake and
you're going like wow I know I made a
mistake
or the ones where you feel like you did
everything right everything you could
and it just Stillman
that's such a fantastic question well
hopefully both of those types of
experiences could again provide insight
education self-knowledge and some type
of strengthening in the end but I feel
like the the first one the first one is
is more painful because all you'd ever
want is to feel like you gave everything
you had to the science to be alive
whatever happens you have to then just
take him stride is that it was meant to
happen right if you truly felt like you
you know hesitated didn't flip to a
trust that instinct didn't follow this
purpose or this call and basically
wasted your life battery me would be
much harder even if it was just a day of
your life or ten years or right the
whole thing I thought you're gonna go
with the Oprah answer where I hope I
would learn either way and then you gave
an actually life to vet him to know you
know yeah that I would say for me it's
it's one of those things where yeah the
mistakes are like you know those are
what keep me up at night when I'm facing
it though and it's like I've done
everything because you know I didn't I
really I wouldn't say have a privileged
childhood I'm very privileged that I
have a great family you know I grew up
in a socialist province where they
thought I was basically learning
disabled because I had to go to French
schools and it wasn't my first language
and it was the language laws I mean just
discriminatory language lack in Quebec
yeah and but I am very very grateful and
I have the best father and mother and
that's for but for me where it was you
know if I was like I've studied for this
test I've done or same thing now you
know I'm prepared for the show and I've
done everything I can and then it still
doesn't work when it happens it's
devastating but I feel like it's
something where you I know I can move
past it because I go well I just have to
correct it move forward whereas even
though you're looking back something
were you made an error those are things
were from alone at night and I'm not
sleeping like oh you know I just winced
it is and there's still things there's
things that I don't allow myself to
think about yeah going back 10 years 15
20 years ago because I've closed that
chapter I said there's nothing I can do
right to fix that I will never make that
mistake again never have right and
that's the only thing I could take away
but it doesn't solve that feeling of it
right I think anything needling in it's
it's bad it's nauseating especially if
it's in the public eye where something
is Google and you're like oh I think
I'll tell you what that was with me and
Fox News and where I have a rule now
right I don't do media unless it's my
friend Dana
and it's because video or this show is
gonna go up right people have the full
thing they can make their judgement they
could hate you they could hate me I'm
okay with that
what's really hard is running a search
and seeing someone take a clip from a
show where I said something because I
was asked something by a host and even
though I said what I meant it's cut in a
way or out of context where people could
misconstrue it I said I'm not okay with
that that's hard that's like almost of
getting into injustice right bad
territory which is true emotional pain
I'm right that that is that's anguish
but better to have that version of
injustice than being thrown in prison
right for life for something you didn't
do or something like that that's true I
mean I've got just more and more excited
about this idea of trying to truly
become like the best person you can be
and it's the hardest thing in the world
it's harder than anything else I ever
wanted to try to achieve like putting on
an album or getting on TV
making money or being successful making
my dreams come true yeah
all these ray self-involved pursuits you
know the entertainment industry yeah
ambition in the traditional sense then
others idea what if I could help
what if I could just be better brother
what if I could be a better son what if
I could be better husband what if I
could be a better friend yeah those were
much like ah listen I really actually
take real world after all this the war
yes driving recording hours staying up
for three days working was not doesn't
even come close to one percent of the
hardest to try to face yourself right
inside out and say it maybe that's what
real life actually is and all the other
stuff is is to facilitate that pursuit
so right now that's a good point but you
know what I would say then it kind of
comes in a roundabout way because I mean
you sold out we're hearing Grand Rapids
you sold out the pyramid scheme I mean
very vast crazy but that's I got to hand
that to them their promotion
well we'll take you downtown if we have
time we'll take him to show you around
it's right around here it's an
incredible town there's a lot of city
pride and grand lettle beloved yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a lot like Ann Arbor or
your your friend there Austin I think
that a big part is like I said it's
contagious is the authenticity and when
you are really just trying to improve
yourself and enjoying what you do that
in itself almost becomes for lack of
like a gimmick because everyone else is
trying to find a gimmick and they're
trying to create this or this is the
marketing tool and I will say this like
you're performing you're performing your
first album right there's no what you're
doing for the hour oh it's a mix oh it's
a mix okay but you know you perform a
lot of these songs right which some of
them are older some of them are newer
but there are a lot of artists who would
say well I don't want to do that I just
want to do new stuff you know like Paul
McCartney goes up and say Starbucks
album you know like we got to hear your
classic stuff and the fact that you've
just seen the genuine genuinely enjoy
pleasing your audience is almost
abnormal now as opposed to like my
artist for me well your art is enjoyable
for all people well that's why I made it
I actually
that's what I was interested in trying
to get but also I like those songs it's
not there's nothing
grueling about me playing party hard
I've explained this to about a very
close friend of mine the other day who
asked if I was sick of doing that song
yeah and and even I am surprised at the
fact that I enjoy playing it now even
more than when it was first written I
don't know why I don't question it
though I just am thankful that this all
this thing is revealing itself to me
what I told him is that song I don't
even feel like I created that song and
that song created me that song created
you know whatever I've gotten to do
that's led me here
I sort of worshipped that because I
wouldn't be here without it so try and
resentful of it or to turn away or I
don't get a creative charge or
inspiration from sort of trashing
everything I've already done I do
realize some people work like that but
that's a lot of people yeah and I don't
know if I want to make because you're
probably friends on name but they like
they showed up and they did something
and they didn't play any of the songs
that people wanted them to play and it
was this whole concept album bullcrap it
was just it was just really tough you
know because these people had paid for a
ticket so I think Billy Billy Joel is
why I know but Billy Joel I have this
opinion that if you're for example in
this pub and if Billy Joel song comes on
you're immediately gonna oh wait there's
something going that makes me want to
tap my foot I love Billy okay there he
goes I'm alive and I agree he played you
know all the songs everybody wanted to
hear and then even deep ones that
weren't his choice maybe you know right
I've had experiences where I've done
shows where I did what I felt like doing
and people were disappointed and didn't
feel good
no I I and I didn't want to push against
that and I learned from experience to
what I were again where I have use where
I'm valuable where I can offer something
that actually is appreciated its I can
play that stuff at home I can do that
other shows make it clear that this show
I'm not gonna be playing my songs and
I've done I've done that but yeah I
would never abandon it's like a tree you
know I don't want to cut down this whole
tree just because I want to build a new
nest in one area
you know what it means yeah this thing
is growing and it kind of takes on a
life of its own after you plant the seed
and you gotta then tend to the tree like
I'm there to protect it and help it and
feed it and grow it and be part of it
and I don't want to have to cut it down
just because I feel like you know making
the new offshoot or something right
yeah and somewhere else feel that way
Billy Joel I think he said he said I'm
never gonna write better songs I did in
my 30s because I'm just I became rich
and fat you know it's kinda like the
fighter George st. Pierre's trainer said
you know it's very hard to get out from
the vet at 5:00 a.m. to train to defend
your title when you're sleeping in silk
sheets that's a very good you know I
think it's very noble and also I
understand artists that don't do that
but you just got to do with this makes
you great well you do seem like you're
in it you can feel like in a good place
to feel very I feel like there's things
happening and I'm thanks for certain
things that we can't talk about but big
projects that maybe in North yes
exciting stuff coming up as always very
surprising things I never would have
expected a million years I've turned
myself over to whatever this thing is
this force this destiny and it is
pulling me along and I'm just doing the
best I can and make the most of it as it
happens well ok where can people best
find you Indra wk dot-com yeah all one
word to double use and then every other
website with a to wk at the end
twitter.com slash
all the social medias mizukami she
didn't get there so do you - yeah I have
it I don't update as much as some do
with the videos every every day I would
like to it takes a lot of discipline I I
stick with Twitter that became my your
thing I just loved how one-dimensional
and pure and short and like sort of so
it felt like you're hanging out at a
party yeah with all these people
chattering backwards we don't even talk
about partying I'm so sick of you very
much hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking my face or watch
this video next to me playing in a box
not Andrew W K he's here but there's
there's another box next to him that you
can click maybe we should put in a box I
don't know